this video is sponsored by me I made a
poster with some t-shirts you can buy
them in the description if you want k
bye oh yeah
guys we've done it we finally made it
we've covered battle of gods
resurrection f the universe six
tournament - Goku black and even
the recruitment ark before this one
leading to this moment where we stand
defiantly at the base of our last
mountain 36 episodes 79 fighters and one
really boring paperweight stand before
us in the finish line alright okay I'm
kidding about the whole paperweight
thing or am i holy wood way to find out
and it's in this my longest review yet
and so I hope you've got your comfy seat
ready some food and a drink because this
is gonna be a ride today I will be
exploring the final chapter of Dragon
Ball super animate to date diving in
depth with multiple episodes expanding
on why I hated and what I loved I'm
totally not mark and this is my review
for Dragon Ball super long complicated
and action-packed tournament of power
[Music]
all right first up quick rundown of the
team the team captain whatever that
means is gone after intense training for
a day and a half next
Niccolo cruel intention on androids 18
and 17 Master Roshi inexplicably Vegeta
after a bunch of time of the chamber
Goku naturally and the wild-card Frieza
the rules eliminate the other universes
participants by knocking them off the
edge of the arena Oh also there's no
flying you get disqualified by taking a
life or by using enhancements so no
poison for frost if everyone on a team
was eliminated then the entire universe
they represent and them get erased
well that's sufficiently terrifying Oh
also seen as I have like 36 episodes to
get through today I've decided to break
these bad boys into groups of three
starting with episodes 96 97 and 98 so
let's dive in unfortunately during the
production of this arc the original
Japanese voice actor of Bulma Hiro
Mitsuru tragically passed away the last
line she recorded for the show being
everyone good luck we're counting on you
I think it goes without saying that she
would be deeply missed by millions
around the world and that her impact on
all of our lives cannot be understated
the first episode itself deals with the
prelude to the tournament during which
Goku actually has a brief interaction
with Geron which effectively sets up
Goku's goal for the entire tournament
get to Gian and battle him in addition
to that we also get Juran's first
sentence it's short and reveals nothing
such as the exposure Turan has received
thus far in addition to this interaction
we get a glimpse of freeze a meeting
Frost for the very first time making a
secret alliance so it's gonna be
interesting to see how that plays out
later on and with those brief
interactions shown to us the tournament
gets underway and the chaos ensues and
that's what I notice a really weird
decision that's made at the very
beginning of the tournament we're almost
every character from universe 7 that
lasts the longest are the first to act
alone
now I can sort of see what they're
trying to go for here the theme of this
arc is very clearly that of trust and
teamwork and so starting for a position
where they are not working as part of a
team makes sense to build a story upon
going from not working as a team to then
learning its value but in doing this
you're throwing literally everyone else
who actually does work as part of a team
from the get-go under a bus which sort
of flies in the face of the entire theme
of this arc
it's not like most of these guys do
whether the tournament as a result of
teamwork for very long either but I'm
getting ahead of myself here as the
tournament commences chaos ensues half
of universe 7 remains in a tight huddle
strategy which honestly is smart as the
other universes Duke it out as the
fighting ensues throughout the
tournament goku vegeta eventually are
cornered by the ninth universe before
completely blowing them away with a
series of attacks throughout the opening
minutes of the event making universe 9
the first to be eliminated from the
tournament of power and ultimately
erased from existence this establishes
that the rules are 100% serious and the
reality of that situation can be seen on
everyone's faces still participating as
they all take pause episodes 99 100 and
101 these are a fun collection of
episodes the first deals with Crillon
primarily as he along with Android 18
confront and eliminate majora from
universe 4 it's a fun little episode
climaxing in a feel-good Crillon moment
but quickly takes the negative turn when
he is blindsided by frost and sent to
the spectators bench
Krillin is the first fighter eliminated
from universe 7 after this Kali flood
decides to confront Goku about wanting
to learn how to turn Super Saiyan blue
which Goku says is way too advanced for
her and that she should instead focus on
the other forms of Super Saiyan Goku in
this moment sort of assumes a mentor
type relationship with cauliflower and
the to end up battling and having a lot
of fun when they are going back and
forth this however seems to really
bother her friend sister pupil who is
kale to cauliflower anyway she begins
going berserk again in this weird green
Super Saiyan form which to be perfectly
honest is almost on par with the
original abroad his motivation at least
when it comes to stakes I don't like
sharing I don't like crying I swear if
the Broly movie a couple years ago
didn't recreate the parolee character
from scratch my head cannon would be
that in order to have the green hair as
a Super Saiyan you have to be really
stupid anyway she pretty much goes on a
rampage throughout the arena
naki around various fighters eventually
landing herself in a position where
Universal Evans most basic fighters all
start ganging up on her Goku and
cauliflower four we had temporary
alliance between the three eventually it
becomes the case the kale and
cauliflower are cornered and need then
to rely on each other's power leading to
kale actually learning how to control
the power temporarily together the two
young Saiyans combine their attacks in a
blast
where looks like an ice-cream I had when
I was a kid and in doing so eliminating
a bunch of fighters from the eleventh
universe the episode itself ends proper
with Goku given the two girls time to
recharge and regain their stamina after
their clash with universe 11 episodes
102 103 and 104 okay so no time to waste
because Brienne literally everyone's
favorite character makes her grand
entrance and demonstration flanked by
two other magical girl parodies together
in this episode they pretty much end up
trying to transform like a whole mess of
times and and don't get me wrong it's a
cool transformation sequence but geez
does this go on and on for the sake of a
joke and saving time and animation
Brienne eventually does get to transform
into her ultimate stage Ripley and your
favorite character in mind and as I've
said she is sort of a parody on the
magical girl genre which I actually like
and her design is ol arias too but that
charm is gone soon after with the
frequency with which she makes the same
gags over and over and over although
that's less of a problem with her and
more of a common trait in Dragon Ball in
general however the episode itself
continues as river ankles on a rampage
around the arena grossing on Fuji de and
knocking out a bunch of no names
seventeen meanwhile is having a great
fight with one of the other magical
growth fighters called cocoon so the
episode itself has some really
imaginative fight sequences and some
great artwork ending in 17 eliminating
both her and Vic al from universe 2
later we see Gohan eliminating China's
president leading to both he and piccolo
fighting the last two members of
universe 10 ultimately winning that
exchange and sealing the fates of that
universe go on looks at the last
fighters locket with a picture of his
family as the fighters and deities
vanished before their eyes Gohan mourns
as the tenth Universe is eliminated and
erased from existence
the stakes are indeed high with universe
10 now done for we then switch gears to
another battle that is getting underway
between hit and Universal Evans dispo
he's joined by his universe 11 teammate
kun she needed Goku to offer hit some
backup utilizing his super saiyan cod
form for the first time since season 1
to match dispo speed together they
eliminate could she but dis boat does
manage to retreat it's actually a faunal
episode and it's almost refreshing to
see something like Super Saiyan God
which up until this point had been
criminally underused episode 105 106 and
107 okay so these episodes are really a
mixed bag what is
what is really bad and another is
actually really good so we're batting
two four three here episode 105 pretty
much focuses on and covers master
Rosie's fight with a duck and it's
actually really touching more
specifically this episode deals with
Master Roshi's thoughts on his life his
philosophy and what he'll be leaving
behind if he does go here and now while
charging what seems to be one last
Kamehameha from the originator of the
technique we receive dialog that
effectively captures my love for an
entire era of Dragon Ball in just a few
short lines and it was most definitely
enough to squeeze a few tears for me too
after this row she falls and lifelessly
to the floor spurring Goku on to
completely forget about the fight he's
having and engaging in right now to rush
to his side Goku somehow miraculously
brings Roshi back to life through some
unknown power and once the old guy
starts to stir Goku quickly revert back
to being his innocent self the same way
he was in early Dragon Ball it's a
tender moment that honestly it worked
really effectively for me the next
episode oh ever is one that primarily
deals with a sniper and tension on who
barely manages to eliminate the single
person bad episode it's ok look it's
really not my thing
personally it really lacked any sense of
suspense and honestly felt out of place
amidst the rest of this tournament so
moving on episode 107 has some really
strong storyboarding when I first saw
Frost receiving instruction from shop at
his palace on what his plan of action
should be for it to subtly fade into the
tournament arena in a flash of lightning
I knew I was in for a treat here it was
seamless and brilliant also within this
episode this weird blue water fighter
magic Isle causes dispo trouble until
Jared finally does something and
eliminates the potentially dangerous
fighter with little effort so that's
pretty cool anyways Frost begins
fighting Master Roshi who is struggling
against it because of course is but get
this frost is suddenly put on the back
foot by row G which is at least to me
hilariously unrealistic but at least
it's not for long and without prior
warning Roshi bursts out the mouth of a
technique on frost
I keep getting surprised by that thing
however Roshi is very much at his limit
and doesn't possess enough strength to
execute the move flawlessly resulting in
frost escape completely taken aback by
this the universe six fighter quickly
formulates a cunning plan that involves
getting the attention of the
firing an attack towards the Saiyan who
blocks it with ease investigating the
situation Vegeta rushes in only to be
suddenly attacked by an old rival
magetta who's defending Frost no armed
with earplugs McKenna now has no obvious
weakness in an effort to help the
cheetah Master Roshi uses the mouth of a
once again but this time Frost redirects
it and uses it on Vegeta instead all
this time he was waiting for this
opportunity sealing Vegeta away in a
vial frost seems to have gotten his
revenge on the same prince turning his
attention once again back to Roshi frost
releases a barrage of blasts during
which Roshi manages to throw a tiny
undetectable blast that meets his mark
breaking the file unleashing Vegeta and
his wrath exploded forth from the prison
in a blue flash of light after this
Frost like the smoke bombs away like a
60s cartoon villain and Vegeta knocks
McKenna out of the ring much like he did
the last time Vegeta respects Roshi
after this but advises him to take stock
of the situation and to eliminate
himself now before something terrible
happens episode 108 109 and 110 the
special in episode 108 the alliance
Frieza made with frost at the
tournament's beginning rears its ugly
head go on his scene struggling with the
yard drive from the second universe when
Frieza
comes in and takes control of the
situation easily as Gohan's backup but
then frost joins the frame changing the
dynamic entirely free said he seemed to
have come to some sort of understanding
which ultimately leads to freeze and
needing to fight Gohan to prove his
loyalty to Frost Frieza plays along and
transforms getting what seems to be the
upper hand on Gohan in essence betraying
his own universe eventually knocking
goin to the side with a brief break from
the action Frieza talks of frost
unloading advise unto Him as if he were
his mentor figure the final piece of
advice that he unloads onto him though
not to trust anyone knocking him out of
the ring much to frost surprise he had
been pulling his punches its entire time
with Gohan who had also been in on this
charade but who cares about that because
now we've got the real meat and potatoes
and I'm not saying that because I'm from
Ireland I'm saying that because this is
when the action gets turned up to 11 you
see episodes 109 and 110 are the
installments that made up the hour-long
TV special that aired together when
broadcast in Japan it covers the end of
Goku's battle with rib Rianne which is
really well animated and the first fight
goku has with jared throughout the
series during his barely being seen to
move but this is where goku forces jared
to move like literally the dude won't
move unless Kaku makes him it's really
fun scene that escalates very quickly
from the get-go and there's tension
because we want to know how Goku matches
up to this wall that Jairam poses
cycling through his base forms Super
Saiyan Warren and two Super Saiyan God
which actually punches his head a smidge
Super Saiyan blue and even Super Saiyan
blue kaio-ken times 20 without any
success unless you consider making a
move a success in which case got him
their fight in this clown Ken variation
of the Super Saiyan blue form is my
favorite in this exchange
Goku beam flung to the arena floor only
to explode back into jaren's face it's
pretty great to see there's also a
gorgeous tracking shot of the two as
they fight around the arena passing all
the other fighters give me a great sense
of scale to the actual occasion things
however become dire as Goku exhausts
pretty much every technique and option
at his disposal well all except one
this Spirit Bomb which happens to have
my favorite accompanying track of the
entire series and that's only the first
half yeah you heard me right this is
only the first
half and that first half ends as gern
forces the spear pawn back onto Goku who
seemingly gets destroyed in the
explosion it's honestly a crazy sight to
behold as the second half begins
everyone is left in awe laughter what's
transpired when suddenly
[Applause]
Goku erupts from the floor presenting to
us the best transformation sequence in
this series not Super Saiyan God our
blooper Saiyan ultra instinct has been
hinted at since episode 5 when Goku's
body acted without him against beerus
this is what I call a transformation
that has been built upon and given the
correct occasion and man is the fight
that follows impressive we see Goku
dodge your attacks with little
difficulty and the action supplied by
toys finest is spectacular in this one
special we get Ryo on a sheet Yuya
Takahashi now k pate and even some no
Toshi schita covering the end of the
fight as Goku charges with one final
attack towards durin before
unfortunately running in a juice at the
last moment before being cast aside with
ease by the monstrous universe 11
warrior the ending of the episode also
is a brilliant callback role reversal
with Frieza offering up his energy to
Goku very reminiscent of what Goku did
for him an emic we interrupt this
tournament for two not hey what's up
guys for the first time ever I've
decided to make some t-shirts I made the
design to celebrate the completion of
Dragon Ball super and I produced it in a
fully colored classic manga style from
the lineart all the way through to the
fully colored and rendered image this
might be my favorite illustration I've
ever done so I hope you guys like it and
if you don't feel like a t-shirt right
now we've got a whole bunch of other
stuff including posters hoodies and mugs
all with this design these will only be
available for a limited time so if you
want to get your TM designed apparel
click the link in the description down
below now back to the tournament episode
111 112 and 113 so this episode pretty
much covers the aftermath of Goku's
fight with jared goku himself is
entirely spent and needs to recuperate
his energy levels again with a nice rest
while this is all transpiring hit
directs his attention towards Geron as
the to begin battling in doing so hit
breaks out a ton of interesting
unpredictable moves against urine but
none of them seemed to work or have that
much of an effect at all though I must
say it is fun to watch the two of them
discover the depths of each other's
abilities firsthand it's also nice to
get longer stretches where we are
exposed to during more eventually hit
manages to restrain journey in another
dimension or something with this new
technique he's been developing but even
that isn't enough and with a dominating
attack Geron eliminates hit in just two
episodes jared has destroyed two of the
Ramdas contestants of the tournament and
yet we still know very little about
Durin's personality next up is pretty
much for all intents and purposes a set
up episode piccolo and Gohan start
fighting the universe six namekians Kaba
becomes Super Saiyan 2 after being saved
and given a pep talk like Vegeta a
drained Goku has trouble with some
robots but cauliflower kale removed them
from the equation essentially this
episode is all about universe 6 and
universe sevens relationship oh and
Frieza eliminates kata - and to be
perfectly honest I'm very disappointed
with what little they did with kavas
character moving on episode 113 is
pretty much all about the fight between
Goku and the remaining universe six
Saiyans really since hit was their
leader and has since been eliminated
cauliflower wants to learn how to turn
Super Saiyan 3 to take charge of her
situation for her universe and so Goku
begins fighting her I actually really
enjoyed this interaction
since Goku is red lightning when it
comes to energy levels he's forced to
rely on his martial arts knowledge while
in his base for as he regains his
stamina slowly he worked his way back up
through the Super Saiyan forms as kale
rejoins the party and as soon as their
teamwork starts to get the better of
Goku he bursts in Super Saiyan 3 easily
overpowering them before reverting back
to Super Saiyan su he still doesn't have
enough stamina to show them everything
he's capable of just yet
Kael on the other hand who knows seems
to be in control of her green haired
Super Saiyan form tries to push herself
farther into the depths of her power
however in doing so she loses herself
once again ending the episode oh and by
the way ever since hit was eliminated
Jared's been sleeping I mean meditating
episode 114 115 and 116 taking off right
from where the previous left off kale is
about to go berserk of once again but
cauliflower once again brings her back
from the brink and together they take on
Goku now armed with even more firepower
the fight is honestly really pretty in
places with gorgeous artwork from you
your takahashi and even some comedic
moments with Frieza and the Power Ranger
guy animated by yuuichi Kurosawa one of
the principal animators from episode 50
that I also loved so much as the action
begins to ramp up Goku is able to use
his God form to great effect against the
two young sands eventually cornering
them and forcing their hand to use their
trump card the
enter her design it's honestly my
favorite of these new Saiyans introduced
in the modern generation of Dragonball
and as the fight progresses it becomes
obvious that Goku won't stand a chance
against her if he remains in his God
form and so to remain competitive he
uses Super Saiyan blue leading kefla to
respond in kind by turning Super Saiyan
herself things are ties in a little
tough for Goku in places but clever uses
of the kaio-ken technique keep it from
losing too many of the exchanges but
that could only last so long Goku is
still feeling the effects of the prior
battles and eventually is sent flying to
the ground with 2 well-placed kicks from
Kappler leading to once again a surge of
dormant energy brewing from deep within
Goku ultra instinct has joined the chat
let's hope this time the stakes are a
lot enough to make a difference the rear
appeal of ultra instinct is once again
getting fantastic treatment in this
series built up - and demonstrated using
appropriate framing and on model Arabic
and honestly what follows is some of the
most fun fight sequences sporting solid
animation and choreography facilitating
the single best finish - aimy Dragon
Ball fight I have ever seen ever in my
life I mean it I cannot begin to
describe how much I love that Kamehameha
grime that would make Tony Hawk proud
performed by Goku when he was seemingly
out of options to dodge against Kepler's
ice cream attack I quite literally
didn't expect it in the slightest and
after that devastating attack from Goku
Khali flying kale are eliminated leaving
just two warriors remaining from their
universe in the tournament and OH
jury is awake again eight episodes 117
118 and 119 the next episode covers with
brianne's battle with android 18 and
eventually 17 as they both work together
to eliminate her after assuming a
massive new form the action is honestly
spectacular with cool pieces of
animation supplied by Ryo on a sheet the
following episode however covers the
remaining two fights from universe 6 to
namekians have taken the absorption
ability explained during the NAM excite
- never-before-seen heights the two of
them now represent their entire namekian
race from universe 6 it's a really cool
and great idea that lends a lot of
credibility to these two utilizing a
ritual established ages and ages ago in
the story all the while this is
happening the androids give Goku some
assistance against the last three
fighters from universe 2 as he
once again completely drained after his
tango with the ultra instinct form
however what follows in this episode is
easily my favorite Gohan fight in the
entire series of Dragon Ball super it
demonstrates his calm demeanor extremely
well as he despite piccolo losing his
cool finds the resolve to not only pick
up piccolo slack but also formulate a
plan of counter-attack he tells piccolo
that while he takes on the two universe
six namekians he should charge his
makankosappo or special beam cannon
depending on your persuasion go on seems
to have bought him enough time but even
that charge isn't enough to pierce the
height of these universe six warriors
resulting in a counter-attack leading to
Piccolo's fainting it's at this point we
are greeted with my personal visual
highlight of the episode standing on
either side of piccolo in a void of
darkness is the spirit of calm E and
nail the commie spirit points in front
of piccolo leading him to come to his
senses as he notices Gohan taking an
attack the same way he did for go on
when he was a child during the Saiyan
saga Gohan still the backbone of the
assault presses the attack on the two
universe six fighters giving piccolo
ample time to charge his makankosappo as
one warrior gets dangerously close to
attacking Gohan the young Saiyan refuses
to flinch having a limitless trust in
his mentor piccolo makes the save this
time and together they eliminate the
last of universe six at the exact same
time Goku and the androids eliminate
universe two two entire universes have
been eliminated in this episode and what
an episode it was the parallels between
this and the collection of moments
during the same saga are not a
coincidence the once terrified child are
able to stick to a plan always dependent
on others to protect him has become a
confident intelligent and tenacious
warrior with boundless trust in his
allies I loved this episode and to cap
it all off there's a very bittersweet
ending as beerus sees his brother vanish
before his eyes unfortunately what
follows this stellar show is something
of a gimmick episode following the
remaining fighters from universe 7
struggling to find and eliminate too
hard to see adversaries and while they
do eliminate them both eventually
piccolo is also eliminated rather
unceremoniously episodes 120 121 and 122
the episode kicks off with Gohan wanted
to give his father and Vegeta a break
from fighting and to take on the robots
from universe 3 alone as things get a
little more hairy the androids join in
and eventually Goku and Vegeta
due to its nice game to see Gohan act
with some sort of agency instead of him
reacting to situations that befall him
that is a change to Gohan in this arc
that is most notable to me and one that
I don't see brought up in conversation
nearly enough the next episode begins
that all the robots joined to create an
organic looking creature called an e
Lassa hey look I don't make up the rules
I just review them but is that eel asset
classed as a fourth separate fighter or
is it just one big new one and if that's
the case then doesn't it count as the
eleventh member of their I don't know
anyways Android 18 is saved by Goku and
eventually sacrifices herself for her
brother so that he can remain in the
tournament 18 is therefore eliminated
which means that universe 7 is now down
to five fighters
[Music]
I want to also make it known that all
this time Jaron has stood and said
almost nothing there's even been scenes
where his teammates asked him questions
and he still says nothing his mean level
commitment to this silent tough-guy
routine is hilarious he slept
I mean meditated in six episodes and
since waking up he has literally stood
silently not fighting mind you not doing
anything for seven episodes thankfully
though episode 122 puts it into that
trend for Jared as well as doing a
fantastic job in setting up the scene at
the very beginning with only two
universes remaining it's almost framed
like a Western close ups to the gloves
hair and ears of various characters
showing the stillness and cabinets
before the storm of conflict to come is
strikingly effective universe 11 and
universe 7 are all that remained three
from universe 11 in jeering dispo and
topo and in universe 7 Goku Frieza
Android 17 Gohan and Vegeta remain and
while the focus is on everyone at the
beginning it most certainly is a Vegeta
episode and Yuya Takahashi animates too
so that's always great kicking things
off as the battle between Goku and durin
quickly becomes a battle that involves
Vegeta demonstrating how he differs as a
fighter to Goku
[Music]
[Applause]
while all this is going on we see Frieza
versus dispo as well as topo versus
Gohan and 17 Vegeta begins scuffling
with cheerin throwing blow after blow
landing summon even getting the trash
talk a bit in response however during
bulldozers through a Gallic con and
almost knocks vegeta out of Bounce
however always defiant he once again
stands before the Titan of universe 11
armed with one last massive attack to
test him with a super saiyan blue
full-powered final flash and it is
awesome containing within it at
determination within vegeta to not chase
Goku any longer but to blaze his own
path to power and to find his own way of
surpassing and while that is nice and
while that is a beautiful sentiment it
doesn't work out leading to Vegeta
getting trapped in a vortex explosion
ball or something by Jared
point is Vegeta he's down for the count
episodes 123 124 and 125 the battle
continues as Goku fights Jared again in
blue but this time tries to implement
strategy either by setting landmine type
energy attacks or by slicing off the
arena beneath him using the same attack
gorilla news against him in the earlier
arc great callback coupled with the
instant transmission I loved it looks
like Jared is done for when I guess
physics be damned like okay I don't
understand if flying doesn't work then
why does this and this isn't just an
isolated incident either there have been
countless moments during this tournament
where combatants might as well have been
flying he shouldn't survive this anyways
the episode ends with Vegeta rejoining
the fight pushing himself to newer bluer
heights I present bloopers Saiyan God
bloopers Saiyan blue honestly the
compositing around this new Vegeta form
is too much for me there are so many
light effects sparkles and CGI fluff
added in post-production I can honestly
barely make out what's happening in
terms of fight choreography Frieza
meanwhile tries to make a deal with
dispo to play for his team if they
resurrect him with the super Dragon
Balls dispo somewhat intelligently
refuses and Frieza transforms into his
golden state watching Frieza act as he
would have during the NAM exciti is
honestly fantastic
and super interesting he never does more
than he needs to and thinks about every
single move he makes and he's always
ready with a terrifying wood liner here
and there - that is while he's in
control and dispo it seems he can turn
the Jets up even more as we see in
pushing Frieza to the edge of the arena
about to be eliminated
Gohan makes the save leading to a short
but poignant and great interaction
between the two of them Gohan is serious
and me likey the to fight and struggle
against dispo leading to Gohan needing
to sacrifice himself for disposal
imitation both are knocked out as a
result now only topo and Gian remain for
the 11th universe and for the 7th Goku
Frieza Vegeta and 17 remain and what
follows this episode is probably one of
the strongest episodes in the tournament
I think in terms of character and it's
very fun so justice lag mikeg man is
fighting 17 who's finding some success
with his inexhaustible energy reserves
proving to be much more of a problem to
top o than he first anticipated however
he does plan his opening and launches a
massive attack towards 17 but at the
last moment right before 17 was about to
be overwhelmed Frieza finds himself in
the right place at the right time unable
to defend himself while holding back
seventy's blast freezer begins
trash-talking top o todd to him and
firing blast after blast at the pride
trooper and this is exactly what Frieza
would do it's very much a cat play with
his food right now but alas the play
must end and end it most certainly does
sandwich in topo between both his and
17s attacks however unluckily for Frieza
moments before he was to knock topo off
the stage
the downed warrior stands to his feet
once again and assumes a power of a god
of destruction
so that's less than ideal for Frieza in
this instance but it does contain a nice
callback to the moment Frieza control
the destroyer energy but this time it
doesn't work out though I'm not sure
what stopped it from completely
destroying Frieza oh the fight with topo
now aid God on destruction fighting 17
resumes leading to a similar instance
where 17 is on the verge of defeat when
standing atop a rocky outcrop
reminiscent of his surprise return on
Namek Frieza defiantly blusters a topo
leading to the near elimination of the
fourth last member of universe 7 Frieza
is now out cold inches from elimination
there's some terrific expressions in
this episode some wonderful animation to
boost and I thoroughly enjoyed it all
episodes 126 127 and 128 the fight
continues as topo gets 17 into a
position of elimination for the third
time when breezes stops it again MVP of
the tournament
don't add me I swear Thapa must think
this guy is a cockroach or something
because he is not going away
at all meanwhile the fighting between
Gian Goku and Vegeta gets too close to
the action of Frieza and 17 causing Topo
to start fighting vegeta in Durin's
place in short they fight Vegeta gets
beaten down and is forced to recall his
past to get a surge of inspiration to
defy the odds and overcome Topo leading
into a recreation of Vegeta sacrifice in
the park I do not like this at all and
I'll explain why next week so Vegeta
crawls out of the crater he sacrificed
himself in with a few scratches and less
clothes cool
so vegeta 17 and goku all team up
against Geron who brushes them all off
without much difficulty at all
throughout this entire tournament Geron
has said nothing of substance done
extremely little and even spent a large
portion of the tournament sleeping and
watching others fight he has been this
emotionless Terminator type character
that literally acts not as a character
but as a plot device and obstacle for
the heroes of universe 7 to overcome but
here we are five episodes from the
finish line and we get I'm not kidding
here a tragic cliche Gerudo backstory
for jeering when I first saw this I
burst out crying with laughter anyway 17
calls bs getting on Durin's nerves to
such an extent that he ends up
sacrificing himself to give Goku Vegeta
the best chance to recover and people
read like sacrificing themselves in this
show
Goku still remains on the floor but
Vegeta stands defiantly albeit with zero
energy left episode 128 is pretty much
wall-to-wall Vegeta with a little bit of
Goku at the end
Vegeta is being beaten to a pulp by
Geron over and over and over again
this was storyboard
heavily corrected by the series
character designer Teddy yoshiyama more
oh I mentioned during my battle of gods
review that he worked on the art for
episode thirteen as well the artworks
similar to that episode is very on model
albeit on the safe side when it comes to
its posing Dragon Ball characters sure
do love to hold their shoulders don't
pay regardless Vegeta keeps getting up
again and again to face Geron with the
final time he does coming from his lucky
boot catching him on a piece of random
debris while he's unconscious and that's
the second time his boots and a random
piece of debris have saved him in this
series despite getting up one last time
Vegeta ends up falling off the stage
leaving Goku alone with Joran but not
before giving him all of his remaining
energy
Goku tries to make this as much of a
contest as he can using the last of his
and Vegeta's energy but alas it's still
not even remotely enough to test or push
Jared leading to once again a beaten and
weakened Goku on the brink of losing the
entire tournament when something starts
to happen ultra instant kicks in one
more time leading to the first major or
significant strike
Geron has taken and if that face is
anything to go by then we are most
certainly in for a treat episodes 129
130 and 131 these final three chapters
are the Holy Trinity of Dragon Ball
super providing payoff to every
substantial thing they did in this arc
and show with each episode in my opinion
being better than the last so how did
they go
Goku and Jaron continue fighting in the
air because who cares a flying is banned
and Goku ends up taking a massive blow
from Jared who threw coke whose last two
times using the form has already studied
and understood its movements well enough
to successfully land a shot on this
unhittable new form of Goku's Vegeta
gives Goku a pep talk from the sidelines
ordering Goku to and I quote step into
the realms of the gods and defeat jeer
in Kakarot hearing this Goku rise
himself yet again explosions enveloped
the arena as yuuichi Kurosawa another
wonderful action animator provides some
great artwork and animation for the
fight to help it feel as big as it
deserves to be
however this desperate flurry doesn't
last long and as fast as it started
Geron has Goku once again pressed down
to the ground and this is when we starts
to notice something an energy building a
sense of stability and offense bubbling
within go
all this time Goku's ultra instant form
had been unrefined and unstable mainly
defensive form however for someone to
truly perfect ultra instinct to masters
they must also be able to attack without
thinking simultaneously taking one last
deep breath accepting the power surging
within him Goku lets out a massive roar
as one looks like a galaxy of lights
surrounds and flows through him Geron
acknowledges and smiles meeting Goku's
power output from atop the high ground
respect is now something Geron has for
Goku taking aim Geron fires the largest
attack the tournament has yet seen
towards the saying that while currently
surging with power is still on a flimsy
foothold inches from defeat the attack
is fired the sound effects blast
accompanied by the roaring sound track
when quiet appearing behind Sheren
holding in his hand the blaster and sent
to him stands Goku shrouded in a phantom
white glow similar to how he appeared
behind him last
only this time he lands consecutive
blows while dodging at the exact same
time he has mastered offense as well as
defense this is mastered ultra instinct
and what follows this unveiling is the
single biggest fight in Dragon Ball
super without exaggeration this is the
most well animated episode of Dragon
Ball and that includes Dragon Ball Z
with it being the treasure gem it is
online and all it's honestly wonderful
to see a show that started off as rough
as it did rise up to be the single best
demonstration of animation in the Dragon
Ball episodic series as a whole
with that said there isn't much
happening here in terms of writing or
story but there is a nice moment where
Goku straight-up says that he isn't a
hero for justice but takes issue and
someone attacks his friends and family
but outside of that it's just
spectacular fight choreography with
every major action and effects animator
working on it in some capacity ending on
a cliffhanger with Goku's body rejecting
mastered ultra instinct to the point of
almost ending him there and then Goku is
done and a swarm I both did and didn't
see coming
Frieza is still in play but also 17 what
the final episode is in my opinion the
best episode of the series by far
without question supplying the most
meaningful
of the show providing the best musical
score inclusions and delivering some of
my absolute favorite lines of not just
this series but the entire series so
let's check it out this final episode
can be broken up into its prelude or pre
climax the climax itself and finally the
conclusion but it's what helps link some
of these parts that I find most
interesting throughout this arc itself
it has been following the three-act
structure and by all means we are well
within the third act now
but this singular episode adheres to its
own self-contained react structure to
perhaps more effectively and closely
than any other episode in this arc thus
far acting not only as the series and
arc climaxes but also the climax to this
episode's singular journey creating a
moment all the more intense and potent
for it one of the most interesting
aspects of this final episode here is
that Goku really isn't the main
character of it he's definitely a major
player but actually acts as more of a
Chekhov's gun than the focus character
in this episode in reality in this
episode characters like Frieza and even
Shirin are the focus and main characters
of the finish each undergoing their own
hero's journey
accepting the call to action
transforming themselves atoning for what
they have done and coming out the other
end different journey in that he
receives a new outlook on life and
Frieza in that he gets a brand new one
but anyway I don't want to get lost in
the weeds of the hero's journey and this
is a video first and foremost about me
reviewing this series I'm just a really
big fan of this finish and I need you
guys to know first off that there is
much more going on in this episode under
the hood then maybe you might have
realized the episode itself begins as a
weakened Geron has to contend with
Android 17 and Frieza 2 characters he
thought had been eliminated despite this
he quickly accepts the call to action
and fights them Frieza takes the lead
against the purple brute but what's
interesting is that the entire episode
centers around the main theme of the arc
and that is trust from the very first
opening line of the episode the exact
theme is mentioned trust by both Frieza
and Juran in their first exchange and
that is most definitely not a
coincidence despite this both he and
Frieza reject the notion of trust and so
begin doing battle relying on their own
strengths to get the job done
Frieza begins taunting cheering about
how he isn't the invincible fighter he
thought he once was and that he isn't
intimidated by him in the slightest this
position freezes character finds himself
in is so interesting to me hurting with
the idea of fighting for good but always
finding a reason to make it about
himself very much in the scenario he is
playing the role of an antihero the same
way Vegeta was while fighting the ginyu
force
unnhhh a mic as Frieza and Gian were
fighting and crashing through the floor
we got an awesome establishing shot that
really demonstrates the scale of the
battle at head offering us perspective
of where Android 17 is right now
relative to them which becomes important
later Frieza is using every single
weapon he has against Geron including
his intellect it's extremely compelling
stuff the scene even manages to pull off
a swerve - in its short time with us
Jared rises to the taunt of freezes
stepping on his tail beginning to pummel
his body like a punching bag looking for
this reaction however Frieza uses his
telekinesis to crush her in between two
boulders before giving way to 17s attack
having successfully flanked into the
correct position taking both Frieza and
jaren off guard the Android surrounds
himself and during with a strong barrier
before creating a massive explosion
around the final fighter from the 11th
universe as the smoke clears
Geron falls to his knees down for the
count Frieza
walks up to 17 saying you certainly went
all out to stop him didn't you - which
17 responds by saying even if I failed I
knew it would be fine if you were still
here 17 at this moment has put all of
his trust in Frieza and hearing this all
Frieza can do is scoff at the idea and
sarcastically quipped before moving on
to finish Jared off Frieza at this point
much like jaren still is has no trust in
anyone crushed by the weight of his
defeat at the hands of Goku and now even
Frieza during Niels because he has been
mentally defeated but cutting through
the Cylons toppled shouts out to his
fallen comrade as Frieza teases that his
friend is obnoxious Jared replies I have
no friends topo continues to criticize
Durin's old way of doing things
training for his pride while trusting no
one topper rejects all of this and in
the face of certain destruction puts all
of his and universe Elevens trust
still in Durin's resolve with this Geron
finally begins to understand what trust
is in himself and in others finding the
mental resolve to pick himself up
exploding with new reserves of energy
this forces Frieza back once standing
alone like he is most comfortable doing
he is forced to stand behind the shield
of an ally that moments ago put his
trust in him and there's tons of
symbolism here Frieza by necessity
needed for his own survival sake to
stand behind Seventeen's defenses but
also needed to strip himself of his
gaudy golden facade to help the shields
integrity meaning the shield only works
if Frieza trusts 17 with his energy
kicking and screaming at 17 to not tell
him what to do it's obvious that he is
still trying to reject the notion of
relying completely on others this loss
of his golden form also communicates
tension to us the audience for reasons
that are abundantly obvious they are
about to run out of energy the shield is
buckling and cracking it's about to give
way when
[Music]
this moment this freaking moment on a
fundamental narrative visual and even
musical level works and I don't use this
word often perfectly and what follows is
my favorite scene in this episode in
this series and maybe even Dragonball
goku by some miracle stands alongside
his teammates one last time
formulating a plan of action 17 is a
take care of backup while he and Frieza
deal with jeering Frieza clearly still
doesn't feel comfortable with this
teasing Goku are you sure you don't want
to stay back - Goku sees through this
issue Frieza has immediate shouting his
name reprimanding his foolish thought
process at such a dire point in the
contest confronting Frieza for the first
time about this side of himself forcing
him to see reason
Goku in this moment is showing the true
strength of his character and his being
like this since the very beginning of
Dragon Ball the flat our character that
shows the truth to those trapped in the
line he says we have all gone well
beyond our limits already if we don't
work together and fight universe seven
is gonna be erased goku then turns his
focus to jeering a changed fighter
partially thanks to him but also his
teammates Goku begins to marvel at the
level of strength this fighter has been
able to muster and that's when the most
important piece of dialogue cuts through
the air without being provoked Frieza
says you haven't forgotten about your
promise to resurrect me have you goku
responds somewhat confused Frieza I'm
asking if you still remember he screams
at Goku so long as you don't break your
promise I'll keep mine you know that
better than anyone
don't you that line was not something
Frieza was expecting but in that one
solitary line it suddenly gives Frieza
pause for thought recontextualizing
everything he understood about what
transpired UNMIK Frieza never trusted
anyone not his forces his father and
most certainly not Goku after he begged
him to spare his life and to give him
energy what made that scene anomic as
powerful as it was wasn't simply the
spectacle of the event but also the
story about how Frieza
defeated himself then and there were
begging on that planet
for a second it Freeza ever considered
trusting anyone at the first opportunity
he's given he would destroy Goku there
and then and we all know how that played
out now faced with that explanation in
the closing moments of the tournament
Frieza is forced to swallow his pride
accept that Goku in this instance might
be on to something
and regardless of whether or not he
agrees with him at this moment he has to
trust him he's not going to make the
same mistake he dynamic this is the best
dialogue exchange in all of super no
question and for the first time in the
history of the show
both Frieza and Goku fight
unconditionally side by side as a team
for the sake of their home and it is
amazing showcasing a phenomenal
storyboard by the genius McCool EEC
Thani who if I'm being honest deserves
an entire video of her own and in
addition to that the bombastic animation
supplied by the incomparable Yuya
Takahashi
really puts the cherry on top of this
battle and what a battle showcasing
teamwork maneuvers by both Goku and
Frieza coming in with a flying knee to
Durin's face making this safe for Goku
at the beginning getting a boost from
Goku later off the wall and then go
could return the favor to Frieza making
the save as the guitar solo slashes
through the action within fading in and
out of his Super Saiyan form which if
I'm being completely honest is a damn
cruel visual and what caps off the end
of the tournament Geron saying this so
this is trust universe 7th power
Geron acknowledges that trust is a
powerful trait to have and not a
weakness this episode banned this
episode I adore it the rest of the
episode is tidy up on the details of the
aftermath of the tournament 17 uses the
balls to revive the Fallen universes and
Frieza loses his halo and gains a life
once again
Oh also a really fun visual easter egg
actually happens right after Frieza gets
his life back Frieza teases waste are
you sure about this I don't intend to
stop my evil ways we then cut to Goku
surrounded by gohan piccalo krillin
Vegeta basically everyone who was around
on Namek that's a really nice touch the
gang then goes home
both Goku and Vegeta tease us about the
future while assuming their classic
poses from their gorge battle and that's
Dragon Ball super z' tournament of power
it's surprisingly easy and enjoyable to
watch as a bingeing experience I will
however say that I recall
complaining about the pacing when it was
on the air week to week which is a
justifiable criticism - I believe there
are some very slow and uneventful
episodes and spots in the arc and if
you're not interested in the character
that gets the screen time that
particular week then you're out of luck
and gotta wait until next week to roll
the dice again I mean there's a reason
why I group these by the three instead
of reviewing them individually but in
saying that I loved her attacks and I
loved them as much as I do
not because of the action that comes
with them but because they act as a
wonderful way to bring characters and
subsequently their emotional journeys
into conflict with each other
leading to those emotional journeys in a
lot of ways finding their resolutions
and I think for the most part the
universe survival arc did that and was
for me the strongest out in the entire
series had by a long shot
perhaps my biggest issue with the arc
can be seen with characters like Jaron
and even Vegeta who could have had much
more of an impact on the story had they
been handled better and perhaps even the
whole tournament could have been made
slightly more cohesive looking back at
it now but overall re watching this left
me with honestly more positive than
negatives to talk about and I'm
genuinely happy for that the music in
parts I believe was used masterfully
well and in oh there's a little less
well in fact going through this series
again has inspired me to study Dragon
Balls music more and to be honest I'm
very excited to share with you all what
I found and notice about this series is
music a lot of you have written to me
privately and publicly on Twitter
Instagram and YouTube reprimanded me for
what I have had to say about the show
you love and to that I say I love the
show too I wouldn't be doing what I'm
doing and talking about this show Dragon
Ball if I didn't love it next week I'm
going to be delivering my final analysis
of this series from start to finish
talking about what I loved and what I
hated in detail and explaining why I
hope you guys enjoyed this trip down
memory lane and I will see you all next
week in the next video thank you so much
for watching
[Music]
you